let's get back to the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 we've had some interesting
phone calls already and I predict that
we will have more let's go next to our
caller from the 9:03 area code caller
from 903 tell us your name where you're
calling from and what your question is
please hi I'm ash
I'm calling from Arkadelphia Arkansas
all right good
ok I was wondering if we're going to do
a long-form piece on economic models or
anyone in particular so we are going to
do one on you know how there's this
talking point ash that some people like
to say which is socialism has never
worked period you I'm sure you've heard
that before from people yeah so I am I
am someone who believes in social
democracy a well regulated and a well
regulated society that properly funds
welfare programs but still has
capitalism as we know it however I also
know enough about history to know that
the talking point that socialism has
never worked is easily debunk able and
one of the most often cited incorrect
talking points when it comes to economic
model so we do have a long form piece of
the script is the script in the research
are probably 80% done and yeah we're
going to be doing one on that and listen
it's not an argument in favor or against
socialism communism capitalism it's sort
of saying if we're even going to talk
about this you kind of need to
understand the history first and so yeah
we've got that up coming and it'll
probably be released during the second
half of August ok all right well thanks
Don I still appreciate yeah thank you
quick and easy Pat a very very simple
one I like that that's very good because
I think a lot of times you hear
Republicans attack Bernie Sanders as a
Democratic Socialist about saying well a
Democratic Socialist is essentially
socialist which is essentially a
communist we know none of that to be
true no it's not true